to mrs cordell my fourth grade teacher
to miss peterson to mr garland to mr
jones to miss wolfe here mrs young mr
chavez mr bodhi fifth and sixth grade to
mr blake to mr lester to mr howard to mr
zarnicki dr john to mrs alvarado to gail
wills and janna souza you know mrs
mayhew to my high school humanities
teacher mrs valentine my kindergarten
teacher
who taught me how to analyze literature
and to write who first introduced me to
the magic of tv and film production who
helped me find my voice in writing who
encouraged me to write my first program
who helped me figure out how to think
about and what i think about so many
different things in the world who
brought so much love and joy into the
classroom and demanded excellence while
treating us with respect who helped me
get over my fear of public speaking who
gave me a book began my love of science
and fiction who believed in us even when
we blew everything up who taught me the
value of telling stories to teach
and listening to other people's stories
who was such an amazing woman i named my
daughter after her
and for making us all feel special all
the time and you were exceedingly
patient with me for helping me discover
my love for writing for pushing me to
always be the best version of myself and
for teaching me that i could accomplish
anything i put my mind to for telling me
i was good at math for making sure that
i knew i could do accelerated work for
encouraging my love of reading and
writing for making me feel welcome in
her classroom as a recent immigrant to
united states for inspiring me to become
a kindergarten teacher in turn you've
touched so many lives
both your students and your student
students more than you'll ever know
thanks mrs mayhew thank you mr blake
thank you mr chavez thank you mr garbett
thank you mrs cordell thank you mrs
graham thank you mr lester thank you mr
howland you've made a huge impact on my
life and so many others
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you
[Music]